hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
you know what III is like so many games
are revealed announced and uncovered
that we miss a few games completely well
for me one of those games was extinction
a fantasy oka killing simulator well
okay it's more than that and features a
few interesting mechanics I think you
should be aware of
so here's six reasons to be excited for
extinction let's set the scene
the world is ravished by war while
mankind has been too busy killing one
another for land and resources another
enemy has quietly become stronger and
now the real war is here humanity is now
pitted against this bunch of predatory
monstrosities
waste to humanity these include the
rivetti but the locals call them bogus
and of course our job is to take down
these big boogers to add a little
fantasy mythology to the mix we will be
playing as a feel who is the last in a
long line of Earth's defenders luckily
for us he's pretty much a super being in
his own right with skills unmatched
high-speed climbing and traversal
Assassin's Creed would be jealous of and
wall running like the Great Prince of
Persia titles he can even slow down time
to give himself a chance to plan his
next move and he can hack and slash with
the best of them
beating ten shades of [ __ ] out of the
millions may be enjoyable but it's the
faceoff with the 150 foot Triveni that
has been most excited about this title
beyond the mountains beyond the trees
beyond the light
they grew stronger in the shadows
and there will be a reckoning so we
understand the enormity of this task
look at the damage the ogre can inflict
smashing a lovely holiday home to pieces
and it's being confirmed in this fight
one hits will equal death so how on
earth do we battle these beasts the
first step is to destroy the armor using
a powerful striking now we have a weak
spot to work on and we do what every
self-respecting olga killer would do cut
off his limbs these limbs will
regenerate over time meaning we need to
be quick to finish this fight of course
the only way to end this battle is with
a subtle bit of decapitation
that fight may have looked a little easy
that's where each Olga's abilities
behaviors and armor come into play
we are told these will be randomly
generated and will keep us on our toes
and unable to predict the August actions
in only a handful at previews we've
already seen around 30 different olgas
two fights to break that down a little
more of this Rivini has golden armor
which requires much more precise attacks
to destroy each latch additional time
will probably result in the augurs limbs
regenerating again adding to the
difficulty even the helm has two latches
before you can end the fight
the feeling of Shadow of the Colossus is
profound one tiny individual taking down
an enemy they seemingly have no way of
defeating some people also see
similarities with attack on Titan
probably due to the sheer size and scale
of the main enemy with Shadow of the
Colossus being remade for ps4 and attack
on Titan second outing coming in early
2018
this means this genre of giant killing
is highly competitive but all three
games have different elements which
distance themselves from one another
this is no longer
it is an entire nation
this soldier is all that stares
between humanity
and extinction
we've been a shot of a story-driven
campaign with many side missions once
all that is complete the skirmish mode
allows us to create battlegrounds and
challenge other players around the world
and extinction mode is basically a wave
based survival style game you've played
many times before
at present extinction is a single-player
title although with enough requests the
team have hinted there look into a
multiplayer option taking down a
colossus ogre with a friend sounds
absolutely epic to me so there you go
that six reasons to be excited for
extinction extinction is set to be
released in early 2018 and will be a
full-price title I have huge hopes for
this game and I am looking forward to it
but what about you fancy taking down a
150-foot monstrosity I'd love to know
your thoughts I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade I'll see you next time
[Music]